proxy's the proxy object is used to
define custom behavior when the
properties of a target object are
accessed this will make more sense once
they give you an example but before I
give you an example let me just show you
this Intex we got VAR p equals new proxy
and then you pass in the target and the
handler a target is just an object
you're passing any object and the
handler explains how it's going to be
different than usual
when you access the object so you can
make things a little different then then
what would normally happen when you try
to do things with the object with the
handler and the methods that are in the
handler are called traps let me give you
an example in this example I'm going to
explain the hand letter first and in
this hand letter we're going to define a
new get method now normally the get
method is just a normal method it's part
of the object like if you look at this
example if we if Bart P was just a
normal object and then we try to do did
PETA a equals one the a is the key and
then the 1 is the value so then if you
just console that long PETA a is just
going to print one because we've
assigned one to two a so now instead of
doing just giving you the normal value
out normally if you did PETA aw gif to
get one we're gonna define something
else to happen when you try to access
that that about that key within the
object so it says return key so it's
gonna say if key is in the target so if
we're searching for a key that's
actually part of the object if that's
true so this is a ternary operator so
it's it's if it's true
this is going to happen if it's false
this is going to happen so if the key
isn't the target we are going to return
that key else we are going to return 37
so look down here we have the the
variable P and then we're gonna make it
a proxy we're gonna pass in this empty
object and then we're gonna put in this
handler so we can now assign things to
just like a normal object PETA a equals
1 PETA B equals undefined and now C
console.log this thing's PETA a and PETA
be well PETA a
is one so it should give us 1 Peter B is
undefined so it should give us undefined
but then look at this next section
console.log C and P well there is no C
and P so and then we're gonna do P that
C there is no C so let's see what
happens let's run them and you can see
it is good for PETA a is giving the 1
and then P type B is giving the
undefined and C is see it's checking to
see if C is NP there is no CMP so we get
false but then when we try to have to
see that P it's gonna give us 37 because
of the the proxy handler up here now
just to kind of make this just to show
you one more thing if I comment then out
and I'm going to put VAR p equals and
now just make an object without the
proxy and if I run that so it's gonna
give you undefined so without without
the proxy when I do P dot C it gives you
undefined but with the proxy instead of
giving you undefined it's gonna give you
thirty seven so proxies just allow you
to to make it so other things can happen
instead of what would normally happen
when you're working with objects let me
give you just one more example I'm going
to scroll down here to example two and
proxies can be used to help validate
data that you're passing in to the
object so before I look at this
validator which is the equivalent of the
handler up here let's look at how we're
creating the the object let person equal
new proxy which an empty object
validator and let's see how it validates
because we're actually trying to make an
object called a person so and we're
trying to set the age of a person so
before we were using the method that the
get method now it's the set method so
when you try to set a value of the
object first it's going to see if the
property trying to set is the age and
then if the type of the the value that
means if what you're pushing into the
age property is not a number or if it's
not a value
console dialog age must be a number and
if the value is less than or equal to
zero
console dialog each must be a positive
number
let's just make that less than zero
because will your age can equal zero and
then after that happens it's going to
assigned the object which is person the
property which will be age the value of
what what you set that and that's gonna
return true so let me put in some more
code and give you this example so if we
try to assign person that age to equal
young let's see what happens
it says age must be a number because
it's not a number if we try to make it
negative thirty let's see what happens
we just look at the bottom age must be a
positive number because that's a
negative number however if we do curse
on that age equals 100 which is
something that that it can be it's gonna
say agency a number agency a posse
number but it doesn't give you any extra
warning when you put H equals 100 and
then I'm just going to do console.log
age and I clear the console really quick
and run that and then it's many console
dialogue the 100 now in this specific
example even it's still assigning the
the proper to the value so it like for
instance if right under set it says
personal age if I say console.log person
age and I run that see it's still going
to log the word young but instead of in
an actual program you would have put
console log here you would make this an
error and then it would never get to the
line down here where it assigns the
value but I just did console down long
so you can see what I was doing here
thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes check the description for links
to more information please subscribe and
remember use your code for good